so it's come to this
where sour patch himself decided to send
me a present from me from him
that's how presents work well well well
my how the mighty have fallen
sorry I missed your patch looks like I
am the winner after all even though you
sent this to me not sponsored you know
which would have been a better present
it one less inside this box is a
contract for a sponsorship with sour
patch which would be just delightful and
well-deserved the how am I gonna open
this Oh what was me what tool could I
possibly use to open this box
Oh bequeathed me upon us tool with which
to [ __ ] in shakespeare language um
open it
and used by me to shovel among other
things get wide for this there's a real
sour patch child in here fine if they
didn't intend for me to open this via
shovel they weren't watching my videos
properly this dagger through the heart
of a vampire never really killed a
vampire before Yeah right it's awfully
colorful on the inside there's a letter
mm-hmm I'm assuming this is a transfer
of ownership for the corporation of sour
patch to me Wow look at you you're a
chosen one a chosen one not be chosen
one just say chosen one a diamond in the
rough rough a cream in our crop okay
that last one was a little weird we know
not only do you get the curry seven Sour
Patch Kids colorways the coolest candy
inspired shoes on the planet you also
get a whole two pounds of sour patch
kids candy the coolest two pounds of
candy on the planet custom mix is now
available on the new sour patch kids
comm hashtag add just you know share the
love two pounds certainly wasn't meant
to be no by yourself as excited as you
are an inclined as you may be to share
your thoughts with your friends and
followers we need to remind you that
federal law requires you to be
transparent about the fact that we gave
it to you so if you do post something
about something we sent you just let
them know that it was a gift from your
friends and sour patch kids and Under
Armour by saying something like sour
patch kids and Under Armour just gave me
let me get this straight sorry bud
you sent me a brand deal without the
hey you gave me all the obligations of
making a video curtail to sell your
product without anything for me
Oh question question in the audience yes
right so PR hinges on the fact that I
actually give a [ __ ] about what you're
sending me okay we're knee-deep in they
asked for this they asked for this they
asked for this they asked for this
they said they asked for this all right
sour patch mister patch how are the kids
cuz I'm gonna do a real nice review of
what this box is all about that's what I
do I want to be very clear I am NOT a
sour patch review channel I am the sour
patch review channel so when you come
knocking on my door bearing gifts
there better be the best damn gifts I've
ever eaten in my life and I've been
disappointed before mr. patch but let's
see let's see okay alright okay what do
we owe ya sour patch kids wonderful
regular name-brand sour patch kids
nothing special about these are a little
bigger than your average kid but yeah
not bad not bad now I'm a pretty good
pretty good pretty good pretty good I
gotta say pretty good pretty good pretty
good pretty good pretty good
Oh more MORE not even boxed up a lot of
wasted plastic you know individually
wrapping is not really good for the
environment just saying oh what else we
got here oh it's markable ours mix sour
patch kids
markiplier snakes I don't play
basketball but that's okay not really my
mix if you don't understand what I do in
my spare time is it mr. patch that's all
right let's see what's in here
[Music]
surprise the box says no say a markup
liars mix but whatever any old
markiplier they're all the same right
what's up red and green I like the blue
the best whatever alright okay so now I
have 2 pounds of sour patch kids you're
right you're right you're right I do
have to review all right okay all right
so they mix they know obviously
obviously the team at sour patch kids
would have done extensive extensive
research tremendous amounts of research
to understand my tastes my desires they
would know what I would like I know I
like a challenge you know they got me
all right first off the bag there were
two rips on both sides both ripped up at
first strike and number two the rip
doesn't even go below the seal if you
look at that that woulda ripped just
straight across on the seal and then I'd
be run into the same problem I am right
now so I got a knock off points this mix
strong-willed as I am alright
it smells like candy looks like a lot of
coating on that one I don't like that
[Music]
hmm honestly she's kind of bland I'm not
even saying this just as a bit like I
bit into that and usually it's like I
don't taste any sour okay that won't I
taste shower okay so it's neither of the
flavors that are my favorite
unfortunately but it's fine could use
some more sour though luckily my lovely
and beautiful girlfriend Amy she is
enabling me to reach my dreams of sour
waste not want not
right I've got this lovely plastic here
so this is citric acid and citric acid
is basically it's what's in like lemons
and stuff but this is probably made
synthetically I think it's also
literally vitamin C not a Harvison sure
about that let's add some sour to this
that's a sour patch punch
listen you want mark lick him up
you know what I'll do it I'll lick these
all dumb Sutra guys in here I'll send it
back to you guys for research you take
that back to the lab you're gonna
recreate that oh oh I give this bag I
got two out of ten for two flavors both
of which I don't like I've heard rumors
of this mythical curry popular in India
mom used to make good curry you know
still does right so I don't know if you
there like shoes you can eat or whatever
[Applause]
look I'm not a man known for taste but
these are literally a walking nightmare
I can't even look at that it hurts my
eyes do they even know enough about me
to get my size right that's the question
on camera Lulu I bet this [ __ ] glows in
the dark
yeah there are my size so they did they
did do good enough for that but I would
never wear these ever unless it was a
costume for a character and it doesn't
even smell like curry I gotta wear him I
guess also I prefer to wear shoes
without laces because more comfortable
and easy but whatever it laces are cool
[Music]
[Applause]
one like the mask of shoes hey there put
them on I don't think I'll ever be able
to take them off I think my feet have
swollen to fill inside them I mean as
far as like a comfort level goes I much
prefer as I said before I might prefer
but hey if I ever wanted the people in
the International Space Station to know
where I am I just put these bad boys on
it's like I'm there oh boy okay so
what's our pet send me I just need to
see if these are the only color shoes
with these what are these curry 7-7
Curry's it's like a name of an Indian
restaurant so it comes in two colors for
sour patch
it comes in insulting green and then my
favorite color red
I'm not even special I my I bet other
people got this I'm the sour patch
review Jan my name's not even on this
letter thank you hashtag ad apparently
[Music]